so the idea of vaccine passports which i
i think we're unlikely to see become a
feature of federal or federal
regulation but much more likely to see
become effective
when big private sector companies
enforce them can't fly on airplanes for
example
maybe can't stay in hotels who knows
yeah that's coercive
obviously and as for the vaccine as you
are
once again you've taken it yourself does
a vaccine passport kind of violate the
principle of patient autonomy
look i think i think mandating
vaccination
does let me let's let's talk take some
time about this about this vaccine
passport i think it's going to be a
disaster
an absolute desire look we can't even
get our act together
to get people to register to vote
properly
youth good let me ask you a question who
do you think's going to get excluded
from this vaccine passport it's not
going to be the nice people in naples
florida or newtown pa
it's going to be the good folks who live
in north philly and west philly totally
true
it's going to be people in washington dc
and in the deep south and
and in western pa who don't have access
don't have the the health literacy that
it requires right
it's going to it's going to be a
disaster for civil rights
for equity it's going to totally
register but but the other
point i wanted to make about this
vaccine passport i think we should not
call it a vaccine pass this should be
if there is any such thing ever it
should be an immunity passport
so in other words if you've had a
natural infection and you can
demonstrate that you have igg levels in
your blood that are protective
or if you've been vaccinated you should
get this thing whatever this thing is
going to be
right i don't agree with this thing ever
coming into existence but if it's going
to come into existence
it should not be a vaccine passport it
should be an immunity passport so if
of course if my brother-in-law or my
sister
ended up getting kovid and i can show
you that they have 85 to 90 times
the level of antibody off baseline
they're immune
why why are we forcing these people to
get vaccinated on top well this raised
the larger question which is
why the focus on the vaccine
and vaccination the focus i imagined of
public health would be public health
but instead the vaccine getting the
vaccine appears to be an
end in itself and i'm not alleging any
kind of malintent or conspiracy but it's
very striking and it makes me nervous